political pressure is growing this
morning in Venezuela where two men
claimed to be the country's rightful
leader the elected president Nicolas
Maduro is trying to hold on to power
president Trump is praising opposition
leader Juan Y dos quote historic
assumption of the presidency and
tweeting the fight for freedom has begun
why no plans has set out his plan for
the country this morning in an address
to the nation and Elizabeth Palmer is in
Venezuela s capital of Caracas where
protesters are demanding change
Elizabeth good morning good morning
every day brings a new twist in this
epic battle for power and right now the
opponents of President Nicolas Maduro
feel that they're on a roll
waving flags and chanting freedom
Venezuelans hit the streets again
yesterday in a peaceful demonstration
against Maduro his rule they say has
ruined Venezuela they've had enough of
food shortages hospitals without drugs
of gross corruption and dirty politics
especially Maduro reelection which they
believed was rigged we want free and
decent elections we deserve them we have
fought for twenty years against this we
can't take it anymore the man leading
the anti Maduro fight joined the
protesters in Caracas when wydo head of
Venezuela's national assembly he's now
been recognized as interim president by
the United States in an op-ed in today's
New York Times
whydo called for global backing the
military's withdrawal of support from
mr. Maduro he wrote is crucial to
enabling a change in government but
Maduro is doubling down state television
broadcast pictures of him calling on
troops to defend their
commander-in-chief and for now the
military appears to be standing firm
Maduro also had a warning for the United
States any military intervention by
America he said would turn into another
Vietnam so clearly the role of the Army
is key and everybody here is watching to
see if there are signs that the military
will switch sides in fact Juan why doe
in
that op-ed in the New York Times does
say that he's already having secret
talks with members of the Armed Forces
John Elizabeth Palmer of course on the
spot there in Venezuela